[MUSIC PLAYING]
Us human beings are such
ambitious creatures.
We dream of cosmic expansion.
We dream to soar the
heavens, to transcend
the biological
shackles that limit us.
I think one of the most
interesting ways in which we
rehearse our own ambitions
is through the use
of metaphorical entities.
Greek and Roman gods
being the best example.
This is a way for us to
safely idealize ourselves.
This is where we can, without
censorship, aspire to be.
And of course, by
labeling them, gods, we
don't have to admit that it's
really us who long for those
attributes and qualities of
omniscience and omnipotence.
Whether it's Bacchus, the Roman
god of wine and intoxication.
Or Morpheus, the god of dreams.
Or Prometheus, who stole
the fire from the gods.
Or Adam, who bit from the
apple, the Tree of Knowledge.
I mean when you look at computer
companies-- like Apple-- that
is the reflection of
that Promethean spirit,
of stealing fire from the gods.
All the world's
knowledge and information
stored in the Google database.
The literalization
of our dream--
our psychedelic Promethean
dream of mind expansion.
To be as gods-- having invented
the gods we can turn into them.
This is the human yearning.
This is what we want.
We should just come out of it.
Admit it to ourselves
already and go
about actualizing this
potentiality within us.
To free the brave, reckless,
gods within us all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]